what if there are other universes just
like ours with an infinite number of
Earth's with uncountable versions of you
and what if we don't have to look too
far to find them maybe a mirror version
of our reality is right here this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we could open a portal to a parallel
universe our universe began when a small
but very hot singularity exploded in the
Big Bang 13.7 billion years ago but
maybe it wasn't the only one to be born
then in physics space and time fuse into
one four-dimensional continuum
space-time
if this space-time is flat and stretches
far beyond the limits of our observation
there is a possibility that it holds
uncountable disconnected universes but
for all we know there are a limited
number of ways the particles in those
other universes can be put together at
some point the realities will have to
start repeating themselves that means in
theory our reality is only a small part
of what's out there and someone just
like you might be living in a parallel
universe similar to our own and that
universe may be as close as a million
trillion trillionth of a centimeter away
although the wall between the universes
might be incredibly small traveling
between them won't be easy but it could
be done all you need is an 85 megawatt
nuclear reactor capable of firing
billions of neutrons on command that's
how a team of physicists working in
tennessee's Oak Ridge Laboratory are
trying to open the gates of a mirror
universe of course they have to find it
first
it all comes from a theory that says if
you beam neutrons at a wall
none should pass through if some do
manage to make it to the other side it
would mean that they've transformed into
mirror images of themselves as they went
through the wall between the two worlds
how do we even know all that
well there's one odd thing about
neutrons in particle beams on average
they last for 14 minutes and 48 seconds
before they decay into protons but if
you place neutrons in a lab bottle
they'll break down 10 seconds faster
it's not something we can explain with
physics yet neutrons are all the same
and there shouldn't be any 10-second
difference in their lifespan regardless
of where they're stored could it be
possible that the neutron experiments
didn't go as expected because physicists
accidentally opened a portal to a mirror
world that would be the first evidence
that a mirror universe exists right next
to our own a mirror world with mirror
atoms maybe even a mirror earth an
entire mirror world almost totally cut
off from ours could you meet another
version of yourself in that mirror world
now it gets a little complicated
even though particle configurations can
repeat themselves the odds of finding a
portal to a parallel universe that's
exactly the same as ours are close to
zero think about it there are an ovum
vision Tilian particles in the universe
that's the number 1 followed by 9000
every single one of them would need to
have had the same interactions for 13.7
billion years to create an identical
universe to what we have now the mirror
universe would most likely have its own
mirror laws of physics but it's hard to
know for sure because nobody has
detected a single mirror particle yet
maybe we shouldn't be searching for
answers in a lab perhaps we should be
looking in space itself
our universe is full of dark matter we
can't observe it directly and we have no
idea what it's made of or how it works
but we know that dark matter is strong
enough to stop galaxies from flying
apart yet we can't find it perhaps the
reason is that dark matter is leaking
from a mirror world in two hours if we
could detect that it would confirm that
a mirror universe exists because we know
that there's five times more Dark Matter
than there is visible matter in the
universe you've got to think that a
mirror universe is much more massive
than the one we live in even if we did
manage to open up a gate into another
world the portal would be incredibly
small too small for you to see anything
without some very powerful lab equipment
we'd still be dealing with neutrons and
protons remember you could only enter
that realm if you had the ability to
shrink yourself to the size of an atom
but that's a story for another what if
[Music]